for a human being who lacks the faith in
God so if you're an atheist can you
still be a good person of course 100 and
there are a lot of religious people were
crappy people how do we understand that
tension well from a religious
perspective what you would say is that
it is perfectly plausible to live
in accordance with a set of rules that
don't damage other people without
believing in God you just might be
understanding the reason for doing that
wrong is what a religious person would
say
um there's the conversation again that I
had with you on basically is you and I
agree I said this to him you and I agree
on nearly everything when it comes to
morality like we probably disagree on 15
to 20 of things the other 80 is because
you grew up in a judeo-christian society
and so do I and we grew up 10 miles from
each other you know around the turn of
the Millennium so there's that
um so you can perfectly well be an
atheist living a good moral decent life
because you can live a good moral decent
life with regard to other people without
believing in God I don't think he built
a society on that because I think that
you know that relies on the sort of
goodness of mankind natural goodness of
mankind I don't believe in the natural
goodness of mankind you don't no I
believe in I believe that man has
created both sinful and with the
capacity for sin in the capacity for
good but if you let them be on their own
isn't doesn't it without social
institutions to shape them I think that
that's very likely to go poorly that's
interesting well we came to something we
disagree on but that may be uh that
might reflect itself in our approach to
Twitter as well I think if humans are
left on their own
uh they they tend towards good
they definitely have the capacity for
good and evil but I one left on their
own there
um I I tend to believe they're good
I think they might be good with limits
what I mean by that is that what the
evidence I think tends to show is that
human beings are quite tribal so what
you'll end up with is people who are
good with their immediate family and
maybe they're immediate neighbors and
then when they're threatened by an
outside tribe then they kill everyone
which is sort of the history of
civilization in the pre-civilizational
era which was a very violent time
pre-civilization later was quite violent